final fantasy explorers is a mash-up of
final fantasy elements built within the
framework of creature tracking games
such as Monster Hunter the seemingly
endless march of quests can get
repetitive and tedious and the economy
is frustrating but it's fanservice at
its finest there's no real plot but
that's fine you're here to kill stuff
and the ability to swap job classes
whenever you want and test out all their
unique weapons and combat styles is a
delight it's like rerolling an MMO
character again and again without
penalty to your strengths progression
quest layouts can feel a bit samey but
it's worth grinding them out to get to
boss battles against giant Dolan's that
present some real tough tactical
challenges then there's the loop
defeating big baddies net too rare goods
and the more of you that team up in
multiplayer the more you'll get so you
can unlock that sweet sephiroth costume
and if you don't have friends you can
always summon an ally monster into
battle and make a cacti are chocobo
watch your back it's frustrating that
you have to pay in-game currency to
start some quests significantly
lightening your pockets when you're
saving harder and Gil for better
equipment but those big bad fights are
worth it final fantasy explorers isn't a
true Final Fantasy game in a sense but
it still hits the sweet spot by sending
you into a strange new world against
magnificent creatures and impossible
odds